Bonjour à tous! Aujourd'hui, à
l'occasion de la sortie du film qui lui est consacré,
je voudrais vous parler de Stephen Hawking et de ses travaux de recherche sur…
la théorie du tout!
Vous avez peut-être vu qu'en France est sorti, il y a quelques jours ce film qui
s'appelle « Une merveilleuse histoire du temps».
…et c'est un film qui retrace la vie du
célèbre astrophysicien Stephen Hawking.
Vous savez peut-être que ce à quoi Stephen Hawking a consacré une bonne partie de sa vie de chercheur,
c'est la recherche de ce qu'on appelle «la théorie du tout»
D'ailleurs c'est le titre en anglais du film, ça s'appelle «The Theory of Everything»
Alors aujourd'hui je voudrais vous
expliquer: Qu'est-ce que c'est la théorie du tout?
Pourquoi on l'appelle comme ça?
Pourquoi on la cherche?
Et puis… qu'est-ce qu'a fait Hawking là dedans?
Pour comprendre ce que c'est que la
théorie du tout,
il faut remonter à la première moitié du 20ème siècle.
Vous savez peut-être qu'à cette
époque
ont eu lieu deux très grandes révolutions en physique fondamentale.
La première, ça a été la découverte
de la théorie de la relativité générale par Einstein.
La théorie de la relativité générale
c'est une théorie de la force de gravité.
En fait, à l'époque où Einstein propose sa théorie,
on avait déjà une théorie de la force de
gravité.
C'était la théorie de Newton: La loidel'attractionuniverselle,
celle qu'on apprend physique au lycée.
Et Einstein est parti d'un principe différent. Il a proposé que
si les corps massif s'attirent, ce n'est pas parce qu'il existe une force entre eux
mais c'est parce qu'ils courbent l'espace-temps.
Alors la théorie d'Einstein, en fait, elle n'apporte pas énormément de choses
nouvelles par rapport à celle de Newton…
sauf quand les objets sont très lourds.
Il y a notamment deux cas très particuliers.
Le premier c'est l'existence des trous
noirs.
La théorie d'Einstein nous dit: « Il existe des régions l'espace
dont rien ne ne peut s'échapper… même pas la lumière!»
…ce qu'on appelle les trous noirs.
Et aujourd'hui on sait que les trous noirs existent,
par exemple il y en a un
qui est tranquillement assis en plein
milieu de notre galaxie
et d'ailleurs vous pouvez regarder dans sa
direction si, en été, vous visez
la constellation du sagittaire.
L'autre grande nouveauté qui a été
apportée par la théorie d'Einstein,
c'est l'idée de l'expansion de l'univers.
La théorie d'Einstein nous dit que,
l'univers est en expansion
et que si on remonte le temps, qu'on remonte le film de l'histoire de l'univers,
il y a 13,8 milliards d'années,
il était dans un état complètement
contracté sur lui-même très dense,
très chaud et c'est ça qu'on appelle
le Big Bang.
Le Big Bang est une conséquence de la
relativité générale.
L'autre grande révolution qui a eu
lieu à peu près à la même période, en parallèle,
c'est la mécanique quantique.
La mécanique quantique c'est un petit
peu l'opposé de la relativité générale,
puisque c'est une théorie de la
matière au niveau microscopique.
Par microscopique, qu'est ce qu'on entend? On entend…
…les atomes… et puis tout ce qui est en dessous, tout ce qu'il y a de plus petit,
les protons, les électrons… toutes les
particules fondamentales.
Et la mécanique quantique,
elle nous décrit un monde qui, au niveau microscopique,
est assez différent du monde
dont on a l'habitude au niveau macroscopique.
Le mieux, pour comprendre ça, c'est de penser à un atome… vous savez,
on représente souvent un atome comme une sorte de système planétaire,
des électrons qui tournent autour des protons,
un peu de la même manière que des
planètes peuvent tourner autour d'une étoile.
En fait, la mécanique quantique
nous dit que les choses se passent d'une
manière assez différente.
Pour les planètes qui tournent autour
d'une étoile,
elles se trouvent, en général, à une
distance donnée de l'étoile
mais elles pourraient se trouver, à priori, à
n'importe quelle autre distance
il n'y a pas de distance imposée.
Au niveau microscopique, pour les
électrons
il y a des orbites imposées. C'est à dire qu'un électron ne peut se trouver qu'à
une certaine distance du proton.
Il peut se trouver sur une orbite, il
peut trouver sur la suivante, mais
il ne peut pas se trouver entre les deux
Les choses sont discontinues, on dit parfois qu'elles sont «quantifiées»,
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui donne son nom à la mécanique quantique.
L'autre grande nouveauté au niveau
microscopique c'est que
les particules peuvent être dans plusieurs
états à la fois.
Vous savez, l'image habituelle qu'on donne, c'est celle du chat de Shrödinger,
le chat qui est à la fois mort et vivant.
Et bien pour un électron qui tourne autour
d'un proton dans un atome,
ça se passe exactement comme ça.
L'électron, il est…
dans toutes les positions de son orbite
à la fois. Il est partout à la fois sur son orbite.
Donc quelque chose de très différent
de ce dont on a l'habitude
nous, au niveau macroscopique.
La mécanique quantique, ça peut vous paraître bizarre mais il faut savoir que ça marche très très bien.
Déjà, c'est ce qui est à la base de toute notre
compréhension actuelle de la physique des particules
…et ce n'est pas seulement dans les
accélérateurs (de particules), puisque
la mécanique quantique, c'est ce qui nous permet de comprendre
comment marchent les semiconducteurs
et donc de faire des transistors des
microprocesseurs…
et donc sans mécanique quantique,
vous ne seriez peut-être pas en train de regarder cette vidéo.
Alors, tout ça c'est très bien mais
assez vite, les physiciens se sont rendus
compte que la mécanique quantique et la
relativité générale étaient deux
théories totalement incompatibles
Ça se voit un peu… en relativité
générale tout est continu,
toutes les choses sont dans un état bien
déterminé.
En mécanique quantique,
les choses sont discontinues, les objets
sont dans plusieurs états à la fois.
donc ces deux théories sont
fondamentalement incompatibles.
Et vous savez, les physiciens… ils aiment bien essayer d'unifier les choses.
S'ils pouvaient avoir une seule théorie qui englobe les deux, ça les arrangerait bien.
Et donc, c'est cette hypothétique
théorie qui engloberait les deux
qu'on appelle – un peu pompeusement –
la théorie du tout
Là vous allez me dire: «Qu'est-ce
qu'on s'en fiche d'avoir une théorie du tout?»
Je vous ai dit «la mécanique quantique c'est pour les objets microscopiques…
…et la relativité générale c'est pour
les objets très lourds».
En général, les objets très
lourds ne sont pas microscopiques
et les objets microscopiques ne sont pas très lourds.
En fait ce n'est pas tout à fait vrai…
on connaît au moins deux cas où on aurait bien besoin d'une théorie
qui regroupe mécanique quantique et
relativité générale.
Le premier c'est pour comprendre ce qu'il
se passe au centre des trous noirs.
Vous savez, un trou noir, ça ne fait qu'accumuler de la matière
toute cette matière tombe au centre du trou noir
et donc au centre du trou noir, on a énormément de matière qui se concentre dans un très petit volume.
Pour comprendre ce qu'il se passe vraiment
au centre d'un trou noir,
il faut qu'on ait une théorie qui
permette de faire à la fois de la
relativité générale et la mécanique
quantique.
Il faut qu'on ait une théorie du tout.
L'autre cas, c'est…
celui des premiers instants du Big Bang.
En fait, dans les premiers instants du
Big Bang,
l'univers était dans un état très très
contracté. Alors il était très lourd…
mais il était tellement contracté que
pour comprendre vraiment ce qui s'est
passé à ce moment-là, il faut qu'on
ait une théorie du tout.
Et c'est très important parce que, vous
savez, on dit souvent
«l'univers est né il y a 13,8 milliards
d'années»
En fait, c'est pas vrai, en fait on n'en
sait rien
Si on veut vraiment comprendre ce qui
s'est passé à ce moment-là,
il faut qu'on ait une théorie qui
permettent de faire de la relativité
générale et de la mécanique quantique
en même temps.
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'a fait Hawking
là-dedans?
Hawking a été le premier,
dans les années 70, à réussir à mélanger untoutpetitpeu
la mécanique quantique et la
relativité générale.
Plus précisément, Hawking travaillait sur la physique destrousnoirs,
et il a montré que si on mettait un peu
de mécanique quantique dans les trous noirs,
on trouvait que les trous noirs émettaient un rayonnement.
On avait l'habitude de dire «Un trou noir
c'est quelque chose qui ne peut
qu'avaler des choses. Ça ne peut rien émettre.»
Et Hawking montre que non: si on
prend en compte la mécanique quantique,
l'image change et les trous noirs
émettent un rayonnement.
Ce rayonnement c'est de l'énergie
et donc si le trou noir émet de l'énergie: sa masse diminue.
Donc les trous noirs peuvent maigrir et
peuvent même disparaître complètement.
C'est ce qu'on appelle l'évaporation
des trous noirs.
Et donc ça a été une petite révolution
puisque, pour la première fois,
quelqu'un arrivait à mélanger unpetitpeu
de la mécanique quantique dans la
relativité générale.
Et en plus, en faisant ça, cela modifiait complètement l'image qu'on avait des trous noirs.
Et donc c'est ça qui reste la grande trouvaille de Hawking,
sa grande découverte scientifique.
D'ailleurs son nom est resté attaché à ça puisque ce rayonnement des trous noirs,
on l'appelle «le rayonnement de Hawking»
Alors aujourd'hui, où est-ce qu'on en
est dans la recherche d'une théorie du tout?
Et bien, en fait, on n'est pas forcément beaucoup
plus loin que là où on était à l'époque de Hawking.
La tentative la plus aboutie
aujourd'hui – en tout cas celle qui
bénéficie du plus de chercheurs et
aussi du plus de publicité–
elle s'appelle la théorie des cordes.
La théorie des cordes, son idée c'est
de reprendre un peu les choses à zéro et de dire:
«Finalement le monde n'est pas fait de
particules
mais il est fait de petits objets uni-dimensionnels,
qui sont des petites cordes
et qui, comme les particules, peuvent se
balader,
interagir, se désintégrer, fusionner, etc.
La théorie des cordes permet
de résoudre un certain nombre de problèmes
qu'on avait quand on essayait de mélanger un
peu naïvement
la relativité générale et la
mécanique quantique.
Il y a juste un prix à payer, c'est que la
théorie des cordes, elle ne marche que
en dix dimensions.
Vous ne pouvez pas faire de théorie des
cordes en quatre dimensions
ou en 18 dimensions… C'est dix dimensions obligatoires.
Une dimension de temps, neuf dimensions d'espace.
Ça c'est un problème, parce que
jusqu'à preuve du contraire, aujourd'hui,
des dimensions d'espace,
on n'en a vu que trois.
Donc il faut expliquer où sont les six autres.
Aujourd'hui, la théorie des cordes
est l'approche la plus développée,
mais elle est encore loin de pouvoir
prétendre à être «la théorie du tout»
Et puis il faut savoir qu'il n'y a pas que la
théorie des cordes dans la vie,
il y a d'autres approches
et notamment, ces vingt dernières
années, il y a une nouvelle approche qui
s'est développée qui s'appelle la
gravité quantique à boucles.
Il ne faut pas vous laisser tromper par
le terme de boucles.
Les boucles de la gravité quantique à boucles
n'ont à peu près rien à voir avec les
cordes de la théorie des cordes
et c'est une approche très intéressante parceque,notamment,
elle fonctionne en quatre dimensions.
C'est-à-dire une dimension de temps
et trois dimensions d'espace.
Et en particulier, les physiciens qui travaillent sur le sujet
ont regardé comment on pouvait comprendre
les premiers instants du Big Bang
en utilisant cette théorie.
Et ce qu'ils ont vu, c'est qu'il était
possible que
notre univers ne soit en fait pas né
il y a 13,8 milliards d'années,
mais soit le résultat…
du rebond d'un univers précédent!
Donc, il faut s'imaginer un univers
précédent qui se serait effondré sur lui même
et qui, juste avant d'atteindre une taille ponctuelle, aurait rebondit
et aurait donné notre univers à nous.
Alors, il faut que je vous dise,
cette approche de la gravité quantique
à boucles,
j'ai un petit faible pour elle parce que
c'était mon sujet de recherche
il y a quelques années.
Je vous le promet: un jour je vous ferai une
vidéo spécifique sur la gravité quantique à boucles.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette
vidéo, j'espère qu'elle vous a plu.
Sachez que vous pouvez vous abonner à la chaîne.
Vous pouvez aussi me retrouver sur mon blog: Scienceétonnante
ainsi que sur Facebook
et sur Twitter. À bientôt!